[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين
نتنياهو يقيل وزير الدفاع بعد معارضته خطط
الاصلاح القضائيه والضغط يشتد عليه من كل
حدب وصوب
حرب كلاميه بين بوتين الرئيس الروسي
يشبهها بتحالفات الحرب العالميه الثانيه
والحلف يصف تصريحاته حول النووي بغير
المسؤوله
من خميس اسود في فرنسا الى اثنين كبير في
المانيا
الاضرابات تعطب انشطه النقل في اكبر
اقتصاد بمنطقه
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكيه يتهم المدير
التنفيذي لتيك توك بالكذب فهل تستطيع
وعشره حضر التطبيق في كل امريكا
[موسيقى]
اقل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو اقال وزير الدفاع في حكومته من
منصبه وذلك بعد معارضه الاخير لخطه
الاصلاحات القضائيه وبعد ان دعى الى وقف
الاصلاحات القضائيه في البلاد ومن المنتظر
بحسب وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه ان يخلفه في
دختر وزير الزراعه الحالي الذي شغل منصب
رئيس الاستخبارات ووزير الامن بوقت سابق
طبعا هذا القرار ادى الى ردود افعال غاضبه
في الشرع الاسرائيلي زعيم المعارضه الذي
كان يشغل منصب نتنياهو اكد ان الاخير يهدد
الامن القومي للبلاد فيما شدد ائتلاف
الوحده الوطنيه الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو
مصمم على القاء اسرائيل في الهاويه مشيرا
الى انه لم يحدث من قبل ان اقيل وزير دفاع
لتحذيره من خطر الامن قاده الاحتجاجات
الاسرائيليه من جهتهم قالوا ان نتنياهو
يتصرف كاديكتاتور اصيله
وننتقل لنشاهد الاحتجاجات المستمره
بالشارع الاسرائيلي طبعا هذه الصور وصلتنا
منذ قليل من امام المركز الحكومي في تل
ابيب اعتراضا على اقاله نتنياهو لوزير
دفعه نذكر بان هذه الاحتجاجات مستمره منذ
اسابيع في العاصمه الاسرائيليه تل ابيب
وهي تعارض الاصلاحات القضائيه التي ينوي
نتنياهو رئيس الحكومه الحاليه القيامه بها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الاحتجاجات مستمره مثل
ما ذكرنا منذ عده اسابيع
والمعارضه الاسرائيليه وايضا ضغوط الشارع
تضغط على
نتانياهو للتوقف عن هذه
الاصلاحات القضائيه ولكن نتنياه مصر على
اجرائها حتى انه منذ يومين صادق الكنيست
على مشروع قانون يشدد من شروط عزل رئيس
الحكومه طبعا الامر الذي يعطيه المزيد من
الحصانه
لنتنياهو نذكر بانه ايضا نتنياهو متهم
بقضايا فساد وخيانه للامانه نشاهد اذا
احتجاجات من امام المركز الحكومي في تل
ابيب بعد اقاله وزير الدفاع
[موسيقى]
ومن القدس ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي اهلا بك زياد معنا يعني وقع
الاحتجاجات ووقع قرار نتنياهو باقاله وزير
دفاعه بدانا نراها مثل ما راينا منذ قليل
بالصور
بالشارع استمرار لهذه الاحتجاجات
هذا صحيح جدا نتنياهو صب الزيت على النار
واشعل الاحتجاجات اكثر بكثير مما كانت
عليه وسنرى ذلك في الايام المقبله ايضا
بهذا المعنى رغم ان الامر قد يكون متوقعا
يعني منذ الامس يعني يتداول اسم دختر كمن
سيخلف جالنت وان جالنت سيقال من قبل
نتنياهو مع ذلك شكل الامر صدمه للحلبه
السياسيه في اسرائيل لان عمليا موقع
الموقف الذي عبر عنه كان موقفا عكس اجماعا
داخل المؤسستين العسكريه والامنيه في
اسرائيل ما قاله يقوله رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي والرئيسي رئيس المشاد وجهاز
المخابرات العامه الشباكيه في اسرائيل كل
يوم تقريبا هو قال ذلك علنا
الصدمه كانت لان جالنتا عمليا لم يصوت لم
يعارض الخطه فعليا في الكنيست فقط اقيل
لانه عبر عن رايه عمليا الذي تناقض مع خطه
نتنياهو ووزير العدل لفين الذي يدفع
باتجاه هذه الخطه طبعا كل الاعلام
الاسرائيلي على الاطلاق ما عدا القناه
الرابعه عشره المقربه من نتنياهو لا يقول
اصلاحات قضائيه غير متداول في اسرائيل هذه
التسميه التسميه هي المحاوله الانقلاب على
نظام النظام السياسي والقضائي في اسرائيل
من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه كما قلت هذا
الامر جره الكثير من ردود الفعل الغاضبه
قد يزيد الان
الازمه داخل حزب الليكود للعلم غالنت
سيبقى نائبا في الكنيست بهذا المعنى
سيخسر نتنياهو التصويت وايضا في امور اخرى
المخطط هو فعلا ان يكون دفتر وزيرا للدفاع
لن التعيين سلسا بمعنى
يلقى معارضه كبيره من هيئه الاركان لان
عمليا هذا
الهبوط بالمظله بعد ان اقيل وزير الدفاع
فقط لانه اراد ان يخرج الجيش من خطر
التفكك بسبب ما يحدث ولانه عمليا قال ما
تقوله التقارير الاستخباراتيه بان ايران
بعيده سته في المئه فقط عن التخصيب
اليورانيوم وان حزب الله قام باختبار
الردع الاسرائيلي من خلال عمليه ماجده
وبالتالي كل هذه الامور رفض نتنياهو حتى
ان يكون هناك جلسه للحكومه الامنيه
المصغره بهذا المعنى هو مصر تماما على
المضي الى اخر الشوط في هذه
التشريعات يعني وانت نشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره من امام المركز الحكومي في تل
ابيب بوعيده اقاله وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
نعم وزاره الدفاع
علق زياد على قرار نتنياهو باقالته ان امن
دوله اسرائيل كان وسيبقى مهمه حياتي ايضا
نقل موقع اكسسوس الامريكي الان عن مسؤولين
اسرائيليين بانه نتنياهو ابلغ جالينت انه
فقد الثقه به لانه يعمل ضد الائتلاف
الحاكم
ومتهما اياه
بعرقله وتقويض جهود التوصل الى حل بشان
مساله التعديلات وعدم التنسيق قبل الادلاء
بتصريحاته وتذكرت هو يعني لم يتخذ اي قرار
هو فقط يعني عبر عن قراره وعن عن عن الراي
ليس ذلك فقط يعني دعينا نشير الى ان يوم
الخميس الماضي كان كانت كتب هذا الخطاب
الذي سمعناه بالامس حرفا بحرف عمليا
نتنياهو استدعاه قبل ان يسافر الى لندن
وسمع لما لديه وقال له
تمهل بعض الوقت وافق قلن لكنه فوجئ بان
نتنياهو بعد ساعه عقد مؤتمرا صحافيا وتشدد
اكثر فيما يخص التشريعات ادرك فورا بان
نتنياهو ليس لديه اينيه لا للتخفيف هذه
الحمله
لاضعاف القضاء او لتعليق الامر لان جلن
طالب عمليا لم يطالب بالغاء الاصلاحات
القضائيه كما تسميها الحكومه طالب فقط
بالتريث شهرا واحدا وفتح حوار مع المعارضه
هذا كل ما طلبه طلبه عمليا جانس جالنت
عفوا فقط للتذكير هذا الثالث وزير الدفاع
يقيله نتني ان لم تخوني الذاكره اقال
اسحاق مردخاي قبل نحو 20 عاما وقال بعدها
مشيع لون وهذا هو وزير الدفاع الثالث الذي
يقيله بنيامين
يعني للدفاع نعم ولكن نتنياهو الان بتصريح
يقول يجب ان نقف جميعا ضد قوه الرفض هو
الان يواجه رفضا ان كان من الحكومه وتمرد
داخل حزب الليكود وايضا تمرد من الجيش
تحديدا جنود وضباط الاحتياط الى اي مدى
حكومه نتنياهو قادره على مقاومه كل هذا
الرفض من جهات متعدده
هي قادره ائتلافيا في الكنيست بمعنى لديها
اختلاف مريح نسبيا حتى لو خسرت اثنين او
ثلاثه من النواب يمكن لها ان تبقى
برلمانيا ولكن شعبيا وفي الشارع الامر
يختلف تماما ولهذا لا تبدو التحذيرات من
خبراء في اسرائيل في الاسابيع الاخيره بان
الامور قد تذهب الى حد المواجهه في الشارع
والى حد الحرب الاهليه لا يبدو الامر فيه
الكثير من المبالغه اليوم في القناه
الثانيه عشره بث تقريرا لم يكن احد ليصدق
في اسرائيل ان يسمع 40 طيارا في الاحتياط
يقولون انه في حال تم اقرار هذه
الخطه فعلى نتنياهو ان ينسى ضرب ايران لن
نشارك في ضربه ايران الان لا حديث فقط عن
مقاطعه التدريبات كما حدث عمليا هؤلاء
يتطوعون للاحتياط لا احد يستطيع ان يفرض
عليهم الذهاب وقياده الطائرات
يقولون الان للقناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه يجب ان يدرك نتنياهو باننا
سنرفض المشاركه في ضربات ضد ايران بعد
اشهر ان قرر ذلك بسبب هذا الانقلاب على
نظام القضائي والسياسي
شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي
على هذه المعلومات الوافيه
وفي هذه الاثناء مشاهدينا طلبت المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه مهنه ياهو الرد على
اتهام منظمه حقوقيه له بازراء المحكمه
وكانت منظمه غير حقيقيه قدمت طلبا للمحكمه
العليا الاتهام نتنياهو بازدرائها وذلك
لادلائه بتصريحات حول التعديلات القضائيه
رغم تاكيد المحكمه ان ذلك يعد تضاربا
للمصالح وطالبت المحكمه نتنياهو بالرد
خلال اسبوع فيما اكدت وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه ان هذه التهمه قد تتسبب في سجن
نتنياهو او تغريمه
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القدس
ايلينيسان المحلل السياسي اهلا بك معنا
الليله سيد لي يعني ان يتخلى نتنياهو في
هذا التوقيت الحساس وفي خضام هذه
الاحتجاجات التي لم تتوقف منذ اسابيع عن
وزير دفاعه جالنت ماذا يعني
اولا بمعنى ان نتنياهو هو ليس نفس ان
نتنياهو الذي كنا نعرفه في الولايات
القادمه عندما كان رئيس الوزراء شيئا ما
تغير في هذا الشخص
ثانيا
عندما فضل نتنياهو
وزير العدل
يا ريت لفين على وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
في الفتره الحساسه عندما
نحن في شهر رمضان المبارك
وهناك تهديدات من قبل منظمه حزب الله
وحركه حماس وتهديدات من قبل ايران هل يعقل
ان رئيس الوزراء بسبب
تصريحات التي افضى بها ربما ربما كانت
اخطا في شيء واحد ان هو لم ينشق هذا
الموضوع مع رئيس الوزراء قبل ان افضى
بتصريحاته يوم امس لان رئيس الوزراء كان
في في لندن وهو لم ينسق هذا الموضوع مع
نتانياه وهذا ممكن هذا الخطا الوحيد الذي
ارتكبه وزير الدفاع ولكن هذا لا يكون
السبب لاقاله وزير الدفاع في هذه الظروف
عندما وزير الدفاع حذر مما هو يراه بعد
اجتماعه
بعد قاده الجيش مع رئيس اركان الجيش وهو
يعي ما يحدث في صفوف الجيش الدفاع
وبين الطيارين الذين كما ذكر قبل قليل من
قبل زياد ان الطيارين يرفضون
اوامر استهداف المنشات الايرانيه في في
ايران ولذلك اعتقد ان هذا الامر يؤدي
الى المزيد من التظاهرات في الشوارع
مع هذه الضغوطات والتظاهرات سيد ايلي يعني
حتى انه هناك انشقاق
وتمرد داخل حزب الليكود
وانا انا اريد
هناك
اربعه اعضاء كنيست من خلال 64 كنيسه في
الائتلاف
الحكوميه وهم يولي ادرجتين رئيس لجنه
الخارجيه
والانفان
ودلال الان اذا نتنياهو يريد تمرير تمرير
القوانين باغلبيه 61 عضو كنيسه
بحيته لا تستطيع محكمه العدل العليا الغاء
هذه القوانين لكونها قوانين اساس التي
اقرتها الحكومه الان في هذه الظروف انا لا
ارى امكانيه ربما اذا لم يعدلوا اربعه
اعضاء كنيست على امكانيه
التصويت كيف يريد نتنياهو تمرير قانون
انتقاه القضاه في محكمه العليا وكما سمعنا
قبل قليل
هناك مرشح لمحكمه رئيس رئيس العليا
رافيبيتون الذي هو خارج خارج
القضاء محكمه العدل العليا وهو طبعا يدعم
نتنياهو بكل الامور السياسيه ولذلك اعتقد
ان لهذه الامور كما شاهدناها هذه الليله
ستكون لها انعكاسات سلبيه اولا على مواصله
العلاقات بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
على نقاط بين اجاليات اليهوديه في الخارج
مع اسرائيل
وكافه العلاقات من خارج
مع حكومه
وما نراه فقط ان الجناح اليمني هو الذي
يؤيد نتنياهو في هذه الامور
ولا اعرف ماذا ستكون انعكاسات على
الائتلاف الحكومي وهل الاعتلاف الحكومي
سيصمت برئاسه نتنياهو لان هناك ستكون هزه
ارضيه اولا في الكود من اقاله وزير الدفاع
ثم هذا الامر سيكون له ايضا انعكاسات على
رؤساء الائتلاف الحكومي لا لا لا ادري
فسيتم الامور في لانها راينا الان ضعضع
الائتلاف الحكومي وفي
جزيلا لك من القدس الينيسان المحلل
السياسي على ارائك واعلام اسرائيلي الان
يتحدث بانه لجنه الدفاع والخارجيه
بالكنيسه الاسرائيلي ستجتمع غدا مع وزير
الدفاع المقال حول التهديد الامن
وتتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
التحقيق في تقديم ملياردير صيني معتقل في
نيويورك لاموال لمقربين منب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد النووي ثم النووي مصطلح
استخدمه ويستخدمه بوتين دوما في خطاباته
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب والنووي التكتيكي جزء
منه ما اثار الذعره في العالم حلف الناتو
اليوم استغربت تصريحات الروسيه واكد انه
لم يرصد اي تغييرات في موقف روسيا النووي
تدفع الحلف للتحرك وهو ما اكدته واشنطن
ايضا الناتو وصف التهديدات الروسيه
النوويه بالخطيره وغير المسؤوله واكد انه
متيقظ ويراقب هذه التهديدات عن كثب
اوكرانيا هي الاخرى ردت وضعت الى اجتماع
طارئ لمجلس الامن التابعي للامم المتحده
بشان اعلان روسيا انها ستنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا وقالت الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه في بيان انها تتوقع اجراءات
فعاله من المملكه المتحده والصين
والولايات المتحده
وفرنسا لمواجهه ما وصفته بالابتزاز النووي
من الكريم
لكن ما هو مصطلح الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه المصطلح يشير الى تلك التي
تستخدم لتحقيق مكاسب محدده في ساحه
المعركه خلافا للاسلحه القادره على اباده
المدن فالاسلحه التكتيكيه مشاهدينا مصممه
لانجاز هدف عسكري محدود وفوري وليس
الانتصار في معركه ما ويتم في كثير من
الاوقات استخدام المصطلح لوصف الاسلحه
الاقل في القوه او كميه الطاقه المنطلقه
خلال الانفجار في الاغلب تكون الاسلحه
التكتيكيه على شكل صاروخ او قنابل يتم
اسقاطها من الجو او حتى قذائف مدفعيه كما
نشاهد ذات مدى قصير نسبيا بخلاف طبعا
الرؤوس التقليديه التي تحمل على صواريخ
عابره للقارات اما عن القوه التدميريه
لهذه فتختلف بين قنبله واخرى القدره
التدميريه لاصغر سلاح نووي تكتكي تصل الى
كيلو طن واحد اي ما يعادل 1000 طن من ماده
تي ان تي المتفجره في حين قد يصل حجم
اكبرها الى 100 كيلو طن وفيما يتعلق بعدد
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه عالميا فيصعب
يصعب تحديد الارقام الدقيقه لها لان الدول
على اختلافها لا تنشر ارقاما حول عدد هذه
القنابل لكن وفقا لارقام صادره من مركز
ابحاث تمتلك الولايات المتحده ما يقرب من
230 سلاحا نوويا غير استراتيجيه منها
قنابل يجري نشرها على طائرات في اوروبا
بينما تمتلك روسيا حوالي 2000 سلاح نووي
تكتيكي وعلى المستوى العالمي تمتلك كل من
الصين وكوريا الشماليه والهند ايضا اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه وينضم الينا من واش نطن
الخبير العسكري اسماعيل السوداني اهلا بك
معنا سيد اسماعيل
عن التهديدات او النيه الروسيه بنشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا اليس ذلك
طبيعيا بعد امداد بريطانيا لقياف بيئه
اليورانيوم المنضب
يعني هو هذا
السبب الذي استخدمته القياده او الرئيس
بوتين في
تبرير نشر هذه الاسلحه في بيلاروسيا الا
ان بريطانيا عادت ونفت وجود هذا النوع
اسلحه تقليديه مضاده للدبابات وتعمل على
ايقاف الدبابات لذلك هي لا تشبه الى حد
كبير الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
المنوي او التي لدى روسيا
نيه في نشرها في بيلاروس لا ننسى ان روسيا
في بدايه الحرب
ومنذ ايام الغزو الاولى يعني
وضعت قوه النوويه الروسيه في حاله تاهب
كان القصد منها منع اي تدخل مباشر في هذه
الحرب من قبل امريكا والناتو وحلفاء الغرب
في هذه الحرب الدائره منذ سنه
يعني يعني الاعلان عن هذا في هذا التوقيت
هنالك عدد من الرسائل يعني بالتاكيد ان
روسيا لديها رسائل تريد ان تصلها الى
الغرب والناتو بانها لن تسكت فيما لو
هل هو ابتزاز للغرب فقط ام انه تهديدات
جديه وعندما يرى بوتين بانه هناك حاجه
لاستخدام هذه الاسلحه النوويه سيلجا اليها
يعني لانه هذه التهديدات ليست المره
الاولى التي يطلقها بوتين
يعني هنا يعني التفسير نستطيع ان نقول انه
ابتزاز وبنفس الوقت ايضا بوتين لن يتوانى
في استخدام هذا النوع من الاسلحه فيما لو
تعرضت القوات الروسيه الى نكبه جديده لا
ننسى ان روسيا تعرضت الى ثلاث نكبات في
الحرب او المعركه القائمه في كييف
وخرتون والان هنالك تحضيرات لهجمات في
الربيع من قبل اوكرانيا لاعاده القسم
الاكبر من المدن التي استولت عليها روسيا
لو حصل يعني نكسه جديده وانهيار جديد في
القوات الروسيه لا نستبعد باستخدام السلاح
النووي التكتيكي من اجل ايقاف القوات
الاوكرانيه ابقى معي السيد اسماعيل لنتوقف
مع تصريح اخر من فلاديمير بوتين هناك فارق
بين التعاون والتحالف من وجهه نظر الرئيس
الروسي بوتين اتهم حلف السعي لتشكيل تحالف
عسكريا عالمي منتشر في كل القارات بل
وشبيه بتحالف دول المحور خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه على عكس ما تنوي موسكو
فعله من تعاونها العسكري مع
نيكك
نحن لا نبني حلفا عسكريا مع الصين نعم
لدينا تعاون في مجالس صناعه العسكريه
لنخفي ذلك ليس هذا الامر سرا لدينا تعاون
عسكري وفي مجال التكوين ايضا ومع دول اخرى
وهذا مستمر حتى الان
جديد سيد اسماعيل الخبير العسكري من
واشنطن هل توافق بوتين بان هناك اختلاف
بين تعاونه العسكري مع بكين وما تحاول دول
الناتو حسب تصريحه القيام به وتاليفه بانه
تكتل عالمي يشبه الى حد كبير دول المحور
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
يعني احنا يجب ان نميز بين التعاون
العسكري بالتاكيد التعاون العسكري هو ليس
حلفا عسكريا ليس هنالك عقيده لهذا الحلف
العسكري ليس هنالك خططا دفاعيه وهجوميه
وليس هنالك تمارين مشتركه
وتعد لاي تهديدات مستقبليه التعاون
العسكري كان يكون اي تعاون عسكري بين اي
بلدين ولكن يعني لا نعرف مدى التعاون
العسكري هل سيكون يعني
للمستقبلنوات يعني حلفا مناوئا للحلف
الناتو هذا ما يعني
النوايا المستقبليه واعتقد انه يعني الحرب
الاوكرانيه الجاريه الان
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
ويعني
يعني تداعياتها المستقبليه ستفصح عن هذا
بالتاكيد واعتقد ان روسيا والصين تريدان
بالتاكيد ان يعني تاخذان محلا في دول
العالميه وتزيح الولايات المتحده وحلف
الناتو من السيطره على المقادير العسكريه
في العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن الخبير العسكري
اسماعيل السوداني
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤولون سابقون في منصه لصحيفه واشنطن
بوست ان الملياردار الصيني
قدم اموالا حينما كان جيسون ميلر مؤسس
المنصه رئيسا للشركه قبل ان يعود للعمل في
حمله ترامب الرئاسيه واضاف المسؤولين
السابقين ان هذه المنصه منصه قطر خصصت من
ميزانيتها عشرات الالاف من الدولارات لدعم
شخصيات يمينيه بما في ذلك مستشار ترامب
ستيف
ارسل بعض النواب الجمهوريين في مجلس
النواب الامريكي رساله الى مدعي عام
للضغط عليه وتزويدهم بمعلومات حول لائحه
الاتهامات المحتمله تجاه الرئيس السابق
دون التروم بشان قضيه احتماليه دفعه
اموالا لممثله اباحيه وفق صحيفه موستريجون
واشار ثلاثه من اعضاء المجلس الجمهوريين
في رسالتهم الى ان الاتهام الجنائي
المحتمل لترامب من قبل مدعي محلي تابع
للحزب السياسي المعارض يقود عمل المدعين
العامين المتفانين بحسب وصفهم
ومن متهم يواجه خطر الاعتقال الى مترشح
يبدا حملته الانتخابيه بقوه امام الالاف
من انصاره ترامب انتقد ما وصفه سيطره
الديمقراطيين على القضاء في منطقه
الديمقراطيون تشكيكه بالقضاء الامريكي
تحت شمس ولايه تكساس الدافئه يقود ترامب
حملته الانتخابيه بعيدا عن القضبان واروقت
المحاكم بعد ان اكد مسبقا نيه المحكمه في
اعتقاله واغراقه بالتهم يواجه ترامب اليوم
تهمه الحريه بعد ان ذهب بعيدا باثارته
الفوضى ولعبه على عاطفه الانصار يقول
الديمقراطيون بعيدا عن محكمه منهتا نجح
الرئيس السابق في جمع الالاف من انصاره
لكن ترامب المتهم تقع على هويه ترومبا
المترشح
مدعي نيويورك العام مدفوعا بتعليمات
تلقاها من وزير العدل في قام بالتحقيق حول
قضيه لا تعد جريمه ولا حتى مخالفه وهو
يغادر تكساس اكد ان محكمه نيويورك بصدد
اسقاط القضيه اعلانات كاذبه سوء استخدام
اموال الحمله الانتخابيه عشرات القضايا
المماثله ان لم تكن المئات تهام قد تعود
الى الواجهه مع ارتفاع حمى الانتخابات
طريق العوده الى البيت الابيض اكثر من
بناء برنامج انتخابي لم يتغير منذ سنوات
انه امر فريد حير خبراء القانون لقد
راقبوا احد عشر مليون صفحه من المستندات
ولم يجدوا شيئا ضدي لقد انشات شركه رائعه
ربما يجعلني هذا الرجل الاكثر براءه في
تاريخ بلدنا
القضاء الامريكي تحول الى اهم خصم يعيق
عوده
وفي انتظار ذلك يتسلح المتهم بانصاره
وقبليتهم لغزو الشوارع من اجل ضمان حريه
ترامب المترشح
[موسيقى]
من الخميس الاسود في فرنسا الى الاضراب
الكبير في المانيا المرتقب يوم غد الاثنين
حيث من المتوقع ان تشد البلاد اضرابا
واسعا النطاق لموظفي المطارات والسكك
الحديد حديديه والنقل البحري وشركات الطرق
السريعه والنقل المحلي الذين يطالبون
بزياده اجورهم مع ارتفاع التضخم وبحسب
تقرير لوكاله بلومبرد سيبدا الاضراب
الواسع على مستوى صناعه النقل من منتصف
ليل الاحد لمده 24 ساعه حيث توقفت بالفعل
الخدمات الجويه والسكك الحديديه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
الخلافات في لبنان لا تفنى لكنها تستحدث
من العدم عقارب الساعه تتوقف عند الخلافات
السياسيه توقيتان ومتضرر وحيد المواطن
اللبنا
ني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حضر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الاسبق هندي كيسينجر من حرب
بارده ثانيه اكثر خطوره من الاولى وقال
كيسنجر في مقابله مع صحيفه اسبانيه ان
الحرب البارده الجديده قد تبدا بين
بيكينوا واشنطن كما اعرب عن اعتقاده بان
كلا الدولتين تمتلكان موارد اقتصاديه
متشابهه وهو ما لم تكن عليه الحال خلال
الحرب البارده الاولى
بعض معارك هذه الحرب البارده التي تحدث
عنها كسنجر خاصه بالحرب التكنولوجيه بين
البلدين تطبيق تيك توك في صلب هذه القصه
الان اليوم اكد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن مقر في ان الصين بمقدورها الوصول
بسهوله لبيانات مستخدمي تيك توك في امريكا
وهو ما يستدعي المضيف في اصدار تشريع
يعالج ما وصفه بمخاوف الامن القومي واضاف
مكارثي ان الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك
شوزيتشو لم يكن صادقا اثناء مثوله امام
لجنه الطاقه والتجاره بمجلس النواب
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك حاول
الاسبوع الماضي طمانه الكونجرس بانه
بيانات 150 مليون امريكي على المنصه لن
تنقل للحكومه الصينيه ووسط المطالبات بحظر
التطبيق امريكيا بحثت جون الامكانيه
القيام بذلك الصحيفه اشارت الى ان واشنطن
لديها مجموعه من الادوات الاقتصاديه الا
ان جهود الحظر
تواجهها تحديات قانونيه قبل ثلاثه اعوام
حاول رئيس الامريكي حينها دونالد ترامب
حظر تيك توك بامر تنفيذي الا ان قضيين
اتحاديين قال لا انه ما من سلطه لدى
الرئيس للقيام بذلك
لكن الان بامكان واشنطن سن قوانين كما
يجري حاليا في الكونجرس لمنح الرئيس صراحه
سلطه حظر برامج معينه فيما عدا ذلك كيف
سيتم الحظر هذا هو السؤال بمقدور الولايات
المتحده الضغط على
الشركه الام للتيك توك من اجل بيع التطبيق
لشركه غير صينيه ايضا يمكن للولايات
المتحده اغلاق المنافذ امام شركه تمارس
انشطه تجاريه في الولايات المتحده ومنعها
من التعامل مع تيك توك كذلك تستطيع
الاداره اذا ما شرعت القوانين حرمان تيك
توك من الوصول الى البنوك والمعلنين في
الولايات المتحده ومن الحلول ايضا ان تجبر
الاداره شركه جوجل وابل على حذف التطبيق
من متاجر التطبيقات وهو اجراء لا سابق له
لكن جميع هذه الخطوات قد تثير قلقا كبيرا
في اوساط الشباب خاصه من سيطره التطبيقات
الصينيه على قائمه اكثر التطبيقات التي
يهتم بها الشباب في الولايات المتحده
التطبيقات الصينيه تغزو قلوب الشباب
الامريكيين
في الاسابيع الثلاثه الاولى من هذا الشهر
اربعه من اكثر خمسه تطبيقات تحميلا صينيه
المنشا
تطبيق تيمو للتسوق الالكتروني تطبيق حديث
عمره سبعه اشهر هو التطبيق الاكثر تحميلا
عبر متاجر التطبيقات في الولايات المتحده
في المركز الثاني تطبيق كاب كات لتعديل
الفيديو وهو تابع لتيك توك
في المركز الثالث تطبيق تيك توك
[موسيقى]
متجر تجزئه الازياء شي ان حل في المركز
الرابع
في المركز الخامس جاء فيسبوك وهو التطبيق
الوحيد غير الصيني من بين الخمسه الاوائل
[موسيقى]
ومعنا من واشنطن مايك ساكسون المستشار
الاول للامن الوطني والسبراني في
ثورتواي اهلا بك سيد مايك معنا الليله
يعني الاكيد انه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قادره على حظر تطبيق تيك توك من
الناحيه القانونيه ولكن على المستوى
الشعبي على مستوى يعني حب الشباب الامريكي
كما شاهدنا بالتقرير بانه اربعه من خمس
تطبيقات
للشباب الامريكي هي من منشات صيني كيف
ستستطيع مواجهه الضغط الشعبي لاحقا
ريه سؤالك جيد
الاستفتاءات الاخيره تبين ان الامريكان
منقسمين 50 الى 50 حول
حظر او السماح بالتيك توك
150 مليون مستخدم للتيك توك في الولايات
المتحده ومعظم من يريدون تيك توك لديهم
استخدامات للتيك توك وهناك طرق ايضا كما
اشرتم كوجود
شبكه خاصه
لامكانيه الولوج الى تيك توك من خارج
الطرق الاعتياديه بايجاد مناورات تقنيه
وبالتالي يمكن
[موسيقى]
حضر من عن طريق الابلكيه التطبيقات لكن
هذا لا يمكن كليا فكثر قد يحترمون ذلك لكن
ربما
يكون من الصعب جدا ان يتم تنفيذ ذلك كليا
وبالتالي كيف سيتم الحظر من الناحيه
التقنيه بوجود حلول يعني اصبحت بمتناول
الجميع مثل الفي بي ان مثلا
ارجع هذا ما سيكون عليه الوضع عندما يتم
فتح
الاب ستور الخاص بابل يبين العنوان
للجهاز ويبين من اي منشا هذا هذا
الشخص وبالتالي يمكن ان يبين ان هذا الشخص
من الولايات المتحده وبالتالي لا يمكن ان
يقوم بتحميل التيك توك لكن ان انتقلت الى
كندا او اوروبا او اي مكان اخر سترى
تطبيقات مختلفه
على مخزن التطبيقات التابعه لابل وبالتالي
يمكن ان تغير عنوانك ليبين انك لست
بالولايات المتحده
كثر لا يستخدمون البي بي ان
وقد تكون بالغه التعقيد
وبالتالي
الافكار التي يلجا اليها المعظم هي
اللجوء الى تغيير الموقع وسيكون
ايضا
عدم تنزيل التطبيق ربما هو سيكون محدودا
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد مايك المستشار الاول
الامن الوطني والسبراني في فريدوي
[موسيقى]
محطات كثيره للازمات في لبنان اقتصاديه
تاره بهبوط الليره وسياسيه طاره اخرى
بالفراغ الرئاسي وفشل السياسيين في تجاوز
خلافاتهم في اختيار رئيس للجمهوريه لكن
هناك محطه جديده هي غريبه اكثر منها جديده
عقارب الساعه بعد اسبوعين من اعلان رئيس
حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقات اعتماد
التوقيت الصيفي اعتبارا من منتصف ليل
الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من مارس
الجري تراجع ميقات عن القرار مدفوعا بطلب
من رئيس مجلس النواب نبيه بري بحيث يتم
تقديم اعتبارا من منتصف ليل العشرين وال
21 من ابريل ليصبح لبنان بتوقيتين مختلفين
واحد صيفي واخر شتوي وامام تغير الفصول
ودرجات الحراره هناك ثابت وحيده معاناه
لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
نحن خلينا نعمل
بدات يكون الساعه
يظل الساعه سته من هلا رمضان يا خيي
لا لا
[موسيقى]
طبعا الارتباك صدى لبنان بعد هذا القرار
حيث اعلن وزير التربيه اللبناني عباس
الحلبي في بيان الانتقال الى التوقيت
الصيفي في المؤسسات التربويه والمدارس
والجامعات
عم تطلع براسنا يلا قرار مش مضبوط ومنه
مش قانوني
ونحن كل اشغالنا مرتبطه مع برا يعني ما في
غير هلا انا مثلا شغلي حيكون على التوقيت
تبع المزرعه والجامعه طبعا هي حسب التوقيت
العالمي حياتنا معهم بالقلب ماشيه مع
السياسه للاخر يعني
[موسيقى]
في رابع ايام شهر رمضان بلغ عدد التصاريح
الصادره عن طريق تطبيقي نسك وتوكلنا لاداء
العمره اكثر من مليونين وثمانمائه الف
تصريح فيما يستمر توافذ المعتمرين والزوار
على مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده
نجاه اخرى فاقت اعداد مستخدمي حافلات مكه
السبعه وثلاثين مليون مستخدم منذ بدايه
انطلاق المشروع
ويعمل المشروع على خدمه المعتمرين والزوار
والسكان من خلال محطاته المختلفه في مكه
المكرمه
نبقى بمكه المكرمه وينضم الينا من هناك
عبد الواحد الحميد مراسل العربيه اهلا بك
معنا عبد الواحد يعني برساله سابقه كنت
تتواجد باحدى محطات النقل نقل المعتمرين
وانت الان بوسط شوارع مدينه مكه المكرمه
الاجواء من عندك
اهلا وسهلا بك بالطبع نحن نقف الان قبيل
منطقه محبس الجن التي تعد واحده من
المناطق الرئيسيه والمداخل الرئيسيه
المؤديه للمنطقه المركزيه التي تحيط
بالمسجد الحرام حيث يعني قبل دقائق من
الان انتهت صلاه التراويح بالتالي عمليه
التنظيميه لخروج المصلين والمعتمرين من
المسجد الحرام التي تقوم عليها اداره
المرور من حيث الشوارع الرئيسيه وحتى
المناطق التي يخرج من خلالها المعتمرون
والزوار هناك شوارع خاصه بالمشي هناك
مناطق خاصه للحافلات وهكذا فيما يتعلق بما
يحدث من تنظيم
لعمليه الدخول والخروج في المسجد الحرام
رئاسه شؤون المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي
خصصت اكثر من 151 بابا لدخول المصلين
والمعتمرين والزوار اضافه الى اكثر من 500
موظف ميداني لتطبيق هذه العمليه على ارض
الميدان والتاكد من ثلاثه الدخول وخروج
هؤلاء المعتمرين والزوار نتحدث عن اخر
الارقام من رئاسه شؤون المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي التي تحدثت عن اكثر من
997 الف مصلي ومعتمر يوم امس السبت وهو
الرقم الذي يعد رقما كبيرا مقارنه بالايام
الاولى من شهر رمضان
فيما يتعلق حتى بعمليه الدخول والخروج من
والى المسجد الحرام نتحدث حتى عن المحطات
التي خصصت لاستقبال المعتمرين هناك سبع
محطات داخل مكه المكرمه وخمس محطات على
حدود مكه المكرمه حيث ياتي المعتمرون يعني
يتوقفون بسياراتهم في المحطات على حدود
مكه المكرمه وينتقلون بالحافلات وصولا الى
المسجد الحرام هذه هي العمليات التنظيميه
التي يعني تتواجد في مكه المكرمه لضمان
سهول سهوله دخول وخروج المعتمرين والزوار
الى مكان المكرمه خصوصا بما اننا في
الايام الاولى من شهر رمضان من المتوقع ان
تكون هناك اعداد اكبر خصوصا مع التسهيلات
الكبيره لقدوم المعتمرين من خلال
التاشيرات المختلفه التاشيره السياحيه
وتاشيره العمره والتاشيره الشخصيه وغيرها
من التاشيرات المتاحه للقدوم الى مكه
المكرمه لاداء العمره او حتى للزياره في
المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي شكرا جزيلا
لك من مكه المكرمه عبد الواحد الحميد
مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حاله
الطوارئ في ولايه مسيسيبي بعد عاصفه قويه
اجتاحت الولايه وقال البيت الابيض في بيان
ان بايدن امر بتقديم مساعدات فيدراليه
لتكمله جهود التعافي الحكوميه والمحليه في
المناطق المتضرره
[موسيقى]
نعود مشاهدينا
لنشاهد هذه الصور التي وصلت نموذ قليل عن
الاحتجاجات في تل ابيب اذا هي صور مباشره
نشاهدها الان على الشاشه اعتراضا من
المحتجين الاسرائيليين على اقاله رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيه
لوزير الدفاع طبعا اقاله جالنت من منصبه
تاتي على خلفيه معارضته للتعديلات
القضائيه وايضا دعوته لتعليقها طبعا في ظل
ازمه سياسيه واحتجاجات شعبيه
مستمره للاسبوع الثاني عشر على التوالي في
تل ابيب
ومواقف بطبيعه الحال سياسيه مؤيده وايضا
معارضه
كان هناك اصلا
اجتماع
نتنياهو كان مقرر اليوم
بينه وبين رؤساء احزاب الائتلاف الحاكم
كان من المتوقع ان يناقش تداعيات
مطالبه بوقف خطه التغييرات
بجهاز القضاء ولكنه ارجع الى يوم غد
الاثنين
[موسيقى]
طبعا قرار نتنياهو اتى
وادى الى ردود افعال غاضبه كما نشاهد في
الشارع الاسرائيلي حيث انه زعيم المعارضه
الذي كان سابقا يشغل منصب نتنياهو اكد ان
الاخير
يهدد الامن القومي للبلاد فيما شدد ائتلاف
الوحده الوطنيه الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو
مصمم على القاء اسرائيل في الهاويه ومشيرا
الى انه لم يحدث من قبل ان اقيل وزير دفاع
لتحذيره من خطر امني طبعا قادت الاحتجاجات
الاسرائيليه التي نشاهد صورا مباشره منها
قالوا ان نتنياهو يتصرف كاديكتاتور الصين
نشاهد اذا من جديد هذه الصور وحيث يرفع
العلم الاسرائيلي
وهناك يعني اعتراض على اقاله نت وزير
دفاعه يعني كما وصفه منذ قليل
مراسلنا زياد حلبي وكانه نتنياهو صب الزيت
على النار من خلال هذه الايقاله
نستمع اذا قليلا الى الصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نذكر بانه المشرعين الاسرائيليين من
المقرر ان يصوتوا على بنود اساسيه في
مشروع تعديل النظام القضائي الاسبوع
المقبل لاسيما اليه تعيين القضاه
[تصفيق]
انتهت ساعاتنا لليوم ولكن ملفات العربيه
مستمره مع الزميله ميسون
واخبار الساعه مساء الخير ميسون مساء
الخير راويه طبعا نحن سنخصص اخبار الساعه
كلها لمتابعه ما يجري في اسرائيل بعد
اقاله نتنياهو لوزير الدفاع تفضلي